the layer heil pen show sponsored by step
finance your go to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia high
plan show as usual it is powered by icon plus
capital they're a vc firm and it is sponsored
by blockfi so i'm very excited to get into this
we are talking about one of my favorite stories i
think it is definitely actually my favorite story
um when it comes to crypto especially in the last
two years so joining me on the show today is jamie
ragozinski the founder of wall street bets jamie
welcome to the show how you doing good thank you
how are you doing leia i'm good i'm good i just
when i say what happened last year with the whole
robin hood scandal um that was one of my favorite
one of my favorite things i've ever seen in the
space i have to be honest well it's certainly
one of the craziest things that i've seen as well
right like you've seen a lot of efforts throughout
the years where people of wall street bets decide
to do some shenanigans and they're extremely
clever and they're building on this knowledge but
as they grew in size and in knowledge they were
able to pull off really what is the perfect storm
absolutely so for those that don't know um i
know you've probably told the story a bunch of
times but there's more people that haven't there's
still plenty of people that haven't heard it so
just briefly give us the overview um we'll
start with what is wall street bets give us
the overview of all street bets first so wall
street bets is a community it's most notably
known for the subreddit uh called wall street
bets but it's grown to have this omnipresence
all over social media so these are it's kind of
like a mindset community of people that hang out
and use the markets in a way that's really high
risk or as the name implies like a casino right
they're trying to find these high propensity
uh you know high risk high return trades and
oftentimes that results in people losing money
but uh oftentimes it also results in people making
crazy amounts of money as well and just over a
year ago the community decided to take on wall
street because you guys were sort of tired of
feeling like the little man and you wanted to
have some fun is that a good way to phrase it
you know that's kind of how the media ended up
playing because it sounds sexy that way right
like you have the retailers you have the david
and the goliath and it just sounds it sounds
nice like that it's true it's definitely not
not true but like throughout the years as wall
street bets continue to grow you'd have a lot
of instances where they'd say oh look i just
found this really cool what's called arbitrage
opportunity which is a fancy word for like a you
know relatively low risk uh free money type trade
and they would really creative and sometimes
it would take tremendous amounts of risk
not so much with the actual risk return of the
trade but getting in trouble with regulators or
brokers because they would basically find kind of
like loopholes so what happened with gamestop was
you have this guy uh keith gill or deep i
don't know if you can curse your effing value
i think you can it's up to youtube okay uh and
or rory and kitty and on on youtube he had this
this philosophy so i like gamestop for all these
different reasons took this massive like fifty
thousand dollar trade using stock options which is
pretty risky and all of a sudden his his uh trade
starts making a lot of money and it starts getting
a lot of attention and people start piling on
and then all of a sudden the hedge funds come
out and say oh we're short you know this thing
is not worth anything the pandemic blah blah blah
right and so you start getting the stage of all
the people on one side being kind of challenged
right like and the hedge funds on the other saying
you can't touch me over this is my playground you
can't there's nothing you can do here right and uh
and sure enough they ended up making so much money
like they they bought the stocks and they did it
very sophisticated with stock options with gamma
squeezes like it was a lot more than just people
purchasing stocks uh and it ended up basically
taking the price of gamestop from was about
about five dollars earlier the year prior about
forty dollars at the beginning of this of last
year all the way up to like 500 it was the
highest they got in the after hours trading
so you know obviously that cost a lot of money
to the hedge funds because they had to close out
their short positions about 70 billion i think it
was 70. well that's a lot um okay what was that i
don't know yeah 70 billion just sounds like
it's very possible right like i i don't know
what it was uh but but it definitely was in the
billions i know that much so you know it was this
this idea of finally the retail people are here
you have to pay attention to us make room for
us at this poker table we may be belligerent but
you know we can push your your chip stack around
yeah it was just truly fascinating and i think
the fact that um you know robin hood started um
you know halting the trading so people couldn't
actually um they couldn't buy they could sell
but they couldn't buy what was the what was the
atmosphere like on all street bets at the time
because i'm not part of the community i don't
actually use reddit um so what was it like so
you know this this thing with robin hood stopping
trading it's this kind of misconceived it's a
misconception as to what happened yes they
did stop trading and so that fact is correct
uh but oftentimes it's painted as well the
little guys were winning robin and i had to
put a stop to the bleeding and there's
enough conspiracies that you can link
the way that robin hood gets their money to one
of these payment for order flow companies that's
that's the one that handles this transaction
that ends up bailing out one of these funds
uh so so there was just definitely a lot to
work with but at the end of the day it was a
regulatory issue and all brokers had to basically
stop trading game stuff right like this is a thing
that's complicated it deals with the settlement
process and how it takes forever and then you
know these clearing houses require collateral from
these really volatile stocks so like robin hood
had to come up with like three billion dollars
overnight to be able to allow trading right so
and they did and they effectively did come up
with the three billion dollars but during that
that 24 hour period they had to stop but that
doesn't stop them from being to some extent
uh guilty of not foreseeing this you know
certainly it was one of a kind incident
but still they should have seen the writing on
the wall maybe have more cash on hand who knows
the feeling on wall street bets was absolutely
like what are you doing to me and it was all
against robin hood mainly because robin hood was
the biggest broker that people were using um and
there was definitely a lot of animosity yeah i
mean it was good fun for the whole community just
you know people who were sort of i don't mean
to say anti-establishment but like auntie the
traditional way of doing things right um i want
to take the power back in whatever way it was
good fun for us to sort of see that narrative
play out see you know really just wall street
push an entire generation into whether it's crypto
or decentralization or well it feels good to be
empowered you know you have younger people as a
whole i mean even for when you're a child it's
like you can't eat your candy before dinner you
know you've been told kind of what to do there's
very little influence you can do maybe throw a
tantrum who knows you know then when you're in
in high school maybe college it's like i want to
be able to do these things but i don't have the
money whatever and the boss has to tell me because
i'm a junior level you know you're just used to
to being the the nobody in the scene and this
particular group of people which was young were
had been marginalized by the 2008 financial
crisis you know you have a lot of people with
this mindset and sometimes you see people go
out and protest sometimes people do different
things and this was like this really clever way
of hitting these banks where it hurts you know you
had the 2008 financial crisis where people were
occupying wall street and they put their tents
up there and they lived there forever and you know
it didn't do anything it just it was just it got
some attention to the news it didn't elicit any
type of change but this was effective right and
this was hey look there's there is a way to to
be heard and absolutely it felt really good and
of course you have the component of the rivalry
right like people in general are tribal right
they like to be republican or democrat or they
like to go for you know one football team or the
other football team and it's always going to be
i'm going to beat you whatever it is now you had a
good guy and a bad guy and it was the hedge funds
that were perfect story put their face out there
and these these people that were really enjoying
beating them it's just it's just the perfect story
but i'd like to get some of your background um
because i know you do have a a background in
traditional finance so you have a natural finance
background is that right sort of i studied uh dual
major economics and uh computer engineering and
then eventually once i started i was actually
so yeah it was around the time i started wall
street bets that i'd started a masters in finance
um you know i i figured hey the stock market you
literally click things and you make money and
it's kind of like a video game and it really is so
i'm going to study finance that i can figure and
so then i'm learning about discounted cash flows
and you know like time value of money these crazy
concepts i'm like okay well which point do you
tell me whether to short or long the stock right
yeah and there were there was none of that there
were just there were just math equations that
really didn't apply and when i would try to apply
it it's like well apple's valuation according to
the book value do these excel analysis and all
of a sudden apple's doing crazy things because
whatever president tweets or you know things that
have nothing to do with my excel so i'm like all
right well that was a waste of time all right
i'm just going to figure out how to play with
the stock market by just using it like a game and
and so while i do have that formal background and
the the formal understanding of finance i also
have the hands-on experience of saying like look
in the long term you can apply some finance rules
if that's how you want to do it but if you're just
looking to make money or play or experiment or uh
whatever it is like you literally you're looking
at a line that goes up and down on the screen
and based off of a gut feeling or if you've
stared at enough charts you kind of get a a feel
for whether it's going to go up or down are you
looking at like the fundamentals of a company or
are you looking at geopolitics you know you're
saying you're not looking at excel spreadsheets
so what is it no i'm not looking at anything well
geopolitics kind of because that's uh catalyst
type news right like if you have you know
russia yeah russia is kind of a tricky one because
we've already had russia before we've had china
before we have all these big kind of but there's
there's some much more specific ones uh that that
they could tip the scale something that has to do
with oil is like i don't know some some countries
whatever and then that'll shoot the price up and
down so that that's relevant but the fundamentals
isn't because my time frame is like you know
a couple minutes or a couple hours or a couple
days at most and a lot a lot of times people use
stock options or in my case futures which revolves
so like the fundamentals don't matter between
like you know 9 30 a.m and 9 30 6 a.m right like
these high frequency computers that also
trade all day long they're they're not reading
discounted cash flows look at the statistics and
how things move and and so so occasionally i enjoy
for like academic purposes reading fundamentals of
the company but i don't necessarily map that to um
what the stock is doing so if you you know you've
got i totally understand that makes sense you know
if you're if you're a bit of a gamer it makes
sense why you would sort of see the stock market
like that i think that's a smart way to look at it
so you know if you if you sort of dedicated your
your education to that right you said you did a
masters right yes if you dedicate your education
to that that's a lot of money you truly must you
know believe in it so what point did you realize
that it was rich no i do i like it's i wanted to
study just you know what when you go to school you
get this piece of paper you hang on your wall and
then you give it to the guy over there and then
he gives you a job and he gives you more money
right that's really what it's about like it's
not engineering school like computer engineering
that i really did it because i wanted to gain the
knowledge and i did believe that and a lot of
that stuff and like the intellectual challenge
and same with economics uh but with finance it was
literally just a professional place like all right
well i'm working the system and i got a job and i
want more money so i got to do this thing so it's
it was more of just this this traditional type
of investment in myself but but i always but i
but i never was a very fundamental believer of it
i probably started becoming disillusioned in like
2006-ish there about when i first started kind of
playing with the stock market and and things would
just do things that don't make sense right you
have pre and you see it so often now it's like
why did the price go down they just beat earnings
or whatever um it's just so frequent i'm like all
right uh clearly there's a disconnect and
you see what happens in 2008 shenanigans
and all the the damage that it caused right
people actually losing their houses isn't things
that these aren't no longer the lines that move on
their screen or in addition to being lines they're
affecting my i actually lost my job because of the
2008 crisis so what were you doing to work at the
time i was working at a financial services company
um and and it's so anyway so you have you have
i had this disillusionment i'm like all right
well this thing is clearly just a toy for
people to play with and i and i know that some
people do this professionally where they stare
at their screen and click and make money i
would like to do that too and i don't want
to be able to depend on having a master's degree
or whatever i hedge my bets with the masters but
so that's when it became apparent and the more i
learned about it the more i realized this really
is a game like you have to find cheat codes
you have to find they have fancy words for it
like i said earlier arbitrage but you can use a
meme instead of you know like a math formula to
describe what's happening and it can be just
as effective and so these these cheat codes
and there's been lots of them that are found
by these really creative people that don't
want to play by the same rules like here's
an example in 2019 late 2019 thereabouts
uh this guy figured out that on robin hood you
can basically get infinite margin meaning like
infinite buying power right and so this guy would
it's a little technical not too bad he would
basically buy a covered call like he would buy 100
shares and sell a call and and use his shares as
collateral and then robin hood kind of screwed
up the math behind what happens next because
he gets the money for the call and they didn't
lock it up and blah blah blah so because of the
because margin doubles your money in the account
he all of a sudden had twice the buying power so
he did it two more times and he has four times
of buying power etcetera and and the other and
and then of course the first thing that comes up
through that is i'm going to share this on the
internet with my friends so people like oh let's
see how let's see who wins and there's like the
roster of who's got the biggest margin and people
taking off million dollar trades and here's the
arb on that one right like the arb is alright fine
now you have a million dollars what do you bet on
they're like i don't care apple earnings who knows
because it's not my money i'm you know banks are
too big to fail i'm too small to collect on so
this is a free ticket if i make money it's mine
if i lose money robin hood can't come after me
because they're in trouble for letting me get
away with this and so that's that's the type of
arb that you're not going to see jp morgan do
because there's jp morgan but that's
what you can see from a college kid so uh
and that's what makes this a game and that's
what really does make this a lot of fun
it's just so fascinating to me especially
because you know it there there are these
cheat codes and there is this community which
i mean i know we were sort of saying that the
media likes to present in a certain way but
ultimately it is sort of about you know the
little guy having an opportunity to make as much
money as the big guy can make so in what way do
you think this is sort of going to bring a new
generation into stocks because from my perspective
you know the internet you know forums like
yours are inspiring and educating and empowering
a whole new generation because usually this seems
like something just reserved for the older guys
yeah and that's that's always kind
of been the feeling right this is the
this veil of sophistication they can have
put on a tie in a suit you know i say no no
no you can't do this here and uh and they
use these fancy multi-syllabic words to
try and hide the sophistication but like it's
not it's a line on a screen and it bounces
right so as soon as people figure that out they're
like oh okay um i'd say the combination between
social media right having people have places like
boston best where people can come and chat and
share uh as well as the the brokers that start
becoming a first discount and eventually free
in terms of commissions so now and then you have
things like um fractional shares so that you can
buy little pieces of expensive shares if you
don't have a lot of money no minimum anything
so pretty much you got 20 bucks you can open a
broker and you can just pretty much start playing
around with that and that's pretty huge that and
the interface too it's just this gamified thing
where you know if you want like robin hood did a
lot of things really really smart their interface
if you want to buy stock options
they're complicated right there's like
differential equations that explain all
these greek values and how they move around
but but robin hood just said hey um you want to
buy stock options cool uh do you think the stock
is good what stock do you like apple why do you
think do you think it's going to go up or down
and then you answer with like a color-coded arrow
and you say up and it says okay cool the one you
want is calls instead of puts and then it says how
much do you think it's going to go up by right and
then you'll give it a thing and now now it selects
what's called a strike price then it says when
do you think it's going to go up by and then
and then you put click that button it says all
right this is the thing you want to buy and it's
simplified something that is insanely difficult
and like three easy and then you get confetti
animation congratulations you bought your first
stock option like that's cool that's that's
amazing because i i've always been sort of
somewhat disillusioned with the establishment
um but i never really understood finance at all
how can you right like you know a lot about it
in school um so i just didn't understand it so
my way through was through bitcoin but i would
absolutely love um you know i love things like
that i think that's amazing but because they're
simplifying it so much how important would you
say is for people to actually get involved in the
stock market and learn how to trade uh that that's
a broad question how it depends on what people
want to do with themselves like if i think it's
important that they experiment so that they know
what it's about right at some point uh people will
get jobs they'll want to make money they'll want
to invest in their retirement they're not going
to get these like roth ira these whatever index
funds or just diversified investment and that's
cool that works too right that's the responsible
thing to do if you have a thousand bucks you're
never going to be a millionaire right so you can
experiment to play with that if you have you know
50 000 bucks you probably should put it away so
that you can retire nicely there that that's where
having some experience of the stock market can
help you navigate that part of your life so in
that in that sense the important part is there but
there's another component whereas people want to
say okay well it's not just that i want to know
how to retire i'd actually like to supplement
my income or replace my income and that's where
you say well look anything that's finance related
is going to help you out and playing
with the stock market doesn't mean
going in and understanding what these you know
ratio these financial ratios of the price to
earning and bubble you know it just means reading
about it look at the stuff buy the stock you want
right don't spend too much money but just buy it
look how it behaves figure out why it's behaving
that way and get a feel for it don't get afraid
and uh and that helps you get experience for all
sorts of things like the emotional component of
when you lose money like oh no my thing is down
five percent today um don't freak out and sell
maybe you should buy more whatever and that's
not just stocks right you mentioned bitcoin that's
it's the same thing it's it's just an asset whose
value is driven by a number of people that are
buying and selling it and then that results in
a thing going up or down and you can basically bet
if it's going to go up or down and if you're long
term you want to do it a certain way if you're
short term there's there's different ways to
try and get more leverage out of your trade you
mentioned um you know not being emotional about
it so if there are people out there even like
myself who i have never touched the stock market
i fully just crypto what tips would you would you
give people in terms of you know where to start
but it's the same thing it's no it's no different
if you've been trading crypto like there's not
you're not going to get a different feeling
in your gut when you're losing money
the the lines but if i want to make money like
how do you do that just be aware if you're making
money that's there's also a danger there if
you're like yay look what i did i'm gonna be a
billionaire you just like start fantasizing about
how you just need to repeat that exactly 365 days
ago and by the time you're whatever age you're
gonna have two billion so and then that gets you
to do things that are also silly so both making
money and losing money is this this uh judgment
cloud you know how you make money with stocks is
gonna be a similar answer to how you make money
with crypto if you're doing things with crypto
you can buy the coin and you can see if it goes up
uh or you can start doing some of these defy
exercises where you can buy the thing and
you're going to farm it and stake it and liquidity
pools and generate yields and you can do that kind
of stuff with it or you can do leveraged things
like there's options and futures and these binary
there's a lot of creative things in d5 stocks is
the same thing you have like a bunch of tools it
says all right what do you think do you like this
thing this company you think it's gonna go up
cool buy it and then wait and then hope you're
right and so that's like buying a coin you
want to do something a little more exciting
check out these derivatives check out these
financial instruments and you can do some really
fun stuff especially if you use like stock options
it's it's not even about guessing the direction
of the price sometimes you can actually make money
if you think this the price is going to stay where
it is all right stock options allow you to do that
you buy some and you sell something
there's puts and there's calls and you just
you put this trade together in such a way
that that if the price stays the same way
you actually end up making money right so it gives
you more kind of uh outcomes that you can guess on
how to make money with stocks if you if you want
the real answer like yeah they go off right like
zoom out to 19 whatever as long as whatever
finance tool you like to use lets you go
and the stock used to be really low and
the stock right now is really really high
and it crashed in 2008 and it crashed in
2000 in 1987 and tooth and 1930 whatever 29
um but then it went back up right so if you
literally just want to invest and make money then
just buy stocks and just keep buying stocks
and you're going to make money it's it's
pretty it's a pretty darn close to
certainty thing based on the fact that
basically population is growing right like
it's a crazy way to end up that way but it's
that same thing that you have with bitcoin where
it's like well this thing's limited to however 21
million coins and also the population is growing
and therefore you can have more more demand and
kind of a fixed supply and that's pretty much
what it boils down to yeah and then what is also
huge right now is internet culture and from my
perspective that is affecting the market you know
whether it's um you know characters like elon
musk for example you know pumping doge or whatever
it is so i'd love to get your take on how that
there's like a shift between between like serious
stocks whether it's like tech stocks to more
jokes and how powerful that internet culture is
it's definitely powerful right like i don't think
even the internet knew how powerful it was until
gamestop we'd had inklings of it before like in
2020 when the pandemic was in full force um hurts
the uh rental car company declared bankruptcy
because nobody was traveling and renting cars
so the stock was like two dollars a share was
pretty close to zero and so all the people
from wall street bets are like uh yeah
you're supposed to buy low and sell high
and two dollars is pretty low it's pretty close
to zero there's a lot more numbers if you go
up than if you go down so let's buy this stock
right like it's just you know the thought flawed
but actually somewhat legitimate logic where it's
like yeah if it goes to zero i'll lose 100 percent
right big deal but it can go like you know
it can double or triple sure enough and what
doubler to tripled and and people like that's
cool then around the same time you had this uh
like people are like oh everyone has to work
from home you have to use zoom and so of course
everyone says let's buy zoom and the logic of
buying a company because there's a lot of users is
is okay but but it's not complete right it doesn't
mean that a company is going to be profitable
uh so so critics serious critics are saying these
guys don't know what they're doing did you think
because more customers means better business
why wouldn't it though wait pause why wouldn't
it because to me i feel dumb for not buying zoom
stock no i mean it's it's okay like that analysis
is okay because it's going to mean more revenue
and it gives them kind of more options if they're
not profitable but if you have if you're in the
stage of your business where you have negative
unit economics meaning like you're losing price
per customer because all businesses have this
kind of a j curve the majority of them do where
they start off like at zero zero and then you
start losing money for every unit that you sell
or service that okay and then eventually you
turn into profitability that's uh if you know if
you don't have your numbers correctly then then
having servers are overwhelming you have to scale
up the right time and then the thing goes down at
about time because you weren't ready there's
a lot of things right but understand yeah but
regardless of it people are saying yeah this logic
is incomplete and then not only was that the case
these these people also just went out and bought
the wrong zoom because it was like a ticker symbol
the word zoom z-o-o-m as opposed to the correct
ticker that was zm so people are buying the wrong
company on the wrong premise and that stock went
up like 300 percent the wrong the wrong stock
right i didn't know this that's wild so so people
that were saying you silly you guys are idiots you
don't know what you're doing like you bought the
wrong company and these guys are like yeah but i
made more money than if i bought the right company
so who cares go back to your suit right like
we're having fun over here we're making money
we just killed it with hurts we just killed it
with the wrong zoom let's keep killing
it with whatever else we decide to find
that's amazing i love it it really
is empowering um but you know with
crypto these days and you know you mentioned
defy and liquidity pools and yield farming
and and everything that's going on right
now how relevant do you think stocks are
you know it's it's an existential question for
me because i have the majority of my experience
in stocks and in finance and when bitcoin or some
of these first currencies came out i was like this
is cool right my economics hat says all right this
is an interesting concept you have this currency
and it can't be destructible and it's got scarcity
built into it and it's got this technological
component so i was like all right well i hope they
make it it's a cool experiment um you know and i
was mining it at first uh and and and then it was
just difficult and i just kind of it was really
cumbersome to to use it so then i was just went
back to stocks and i just watched from the uh you
know from the sidelines as the price went up and
i'm like okay cool they made it right bitcoin well
yeah were you wait but what yeah were you mining
oh early like and i lost oh my god so don't worry
it was like 2013. yeah but you know i don't
kick myself in the butt because if i had like
100 bitcoins i would have sold it when i was like
three dollars right i wouldn't have waited till it
was at 60. so i i at least that's what i tell
myself um i agree so uh but anyway so the the
the st sorry people start buying pizzas with
bitcoin on cool they made it right this experiment
was successful um back to my stocks now and
all of a sudden you start seeing these other
coins pop up in ethereum that's not the other
like oh cool all right now there's more of them
all right interesting but there's just numbers on
the screen that go up and down it's another asset
but it doesn't plug into my broker
so not interested they don't know
no stock options on on on cryptos so i'll
just stick to this for now on the liquidity
and so i never reevaluated that stance i just
kept assuming that it was just coins and then
i'm watching like the 2017-18 the ico boom and
i'm seeing everybody doing these new coins i'm
like that's kind of that's annoying right um but
but whatever more coins that go up and down it's
just gonna muddy the waters and then this last
year i was approached by some i got approached
a bazillion times for people like pop my coin and
then last year uh this this one group people said
no no help like come with us we're gonna do a
cool thing where we're gonna merge stocks with
nice with crypto and i'm like all right that's
something i could get behind and so all of a
sudden i popped the hood on this this crypto
thing i was like wait guys this is more than
just coins did you know that you can like do this
automated market like there's there's there's a
way there's a market that's decentralized and
the computer decides based off of these things
that's genius right like it's different because
order books from centralized exchanges have their
merits but but they also have their flaws so like
how did somebody come up with these things and
then you look at these liquidity pools then i'm
looking at these smart contract derivatives also
where you have these leveraged etfs for bitcoin
or whatever these things so that you can buy
leveraged up or leverage down and and as i start
using an experiment i'd like to buy stuff and
figure out how they work later you know i realize
that these etfs that are very similar to the ones
you have in the regular stock market that are
leveraged um they had one different component
where you have the smart contract that that
evaluates the condition of the of the underlying
so that if it's ranging so if the price is pretty
much staying where it is the leverage goes down
and if it starts trending meaning if it shoots up
or shoots down the leverage also gets cranked up
um there's a lot of math of what happens next
but essentially that fixes this flaw that these
leveraged instruments have that make them go to
zero with like near 100 certainty over time right
so i'm like wait wait wait wait crypto has this
smart like etf that can adjust based off of rules
and that makes you more money like why
doesn't wall street have that what's going on
and they don't close on the weekends i knew that
right but like but i felt the benefits of it
yeah especially when elon musk does goes out
there and tweets something it's on a sunday
about tesla and you have these synthetic stocks
that trade 24 7. i'm like yeah i think i'll go
short this now on on the blockchain even if i
don't have the stock like it's just it's a price
tracker basically but like monday morning opens up
and boom i'm like free money i'm like all right so
i'm realizing this ridiculous sophisticated
intelligent like ecosystem where people can
interact financially and it's a heck of a lot
more than just a coin whose price is up or down
right and so then i regret not reevaluating my
stance earlier on because i think that there's uh
a very evident trend where the the the the
lines are blurring between stocks and crypto and
i'm involved currently with the wall street bets
dap uh which does just that like we're creating
etfs that have like a it's like a basket of
mix you can either get crypto with stocks
or whatever um or just stocks or just crypto
and um and you can buy these synthetics or you
can buy these collateralized stocks they'll be
synthetic stocks right but they're both yeah so
right now we have synthetic stocks and we just we
just closed the deal which we're launching at any
moment here in the next coming weeks
where you'll actually be able to purchase
collateralized stocks um so this is this is where
you buy a crypto thing and that crypto thing
represents a stock that somebody goes out and buys
and passes you the dividends and the shareholder
rights obviously when you do that you have to go
through the kyc component because you can't get
a dividend or you can't vote on a company unless
people know who you are but it's done everything
through the blockchain and these guys trade 20
hours a day uh seven days a week which is which is
crazy i have no idea how they do it but they do it
and we've partnered with them fully regulated all
these things so so it's like let's blur the lines
and you have etfs on the in wall street that have
you know they have the bitcoin etf that's been
trying forever finally got a bitcoin's future etf
i don't understand yeah you know why do you say no
to one and yes to the future is one but whatever
gotta walk before you can run i guess yeah and
so like these things are kind of blurring and
and so the whole thing of well is it like stock's
relevant or is crypto gonna be the new thing it's
like yeah they can they're gonna both exist
right they're gonna be the same thing jp
morgan i keep reading about this metaverse thing
that they're doing and you know like it's it's
evident that the wall street people also realize
that there's this thing in crypto and various and
brokers like robin hood you can already buy both
as if they're stocks so that difference is kind of
breaking down but i will say this that i'm talking
that's from the perspective of the retail trader
right like you and me that want to just make
money um you have a component of the the business
which is why does a stock exist and it's for so
businesses can raise money at least you know in
theory that's what was created for and can still
be used for that effect and occasionally it is um
so to that effect just say well no
companies are not going to stop going
public because companies are going to pop
up all the time and they're going to want to
either raise money or pay back their early
investors and that's how you do that part
uh however i i'm now counting the days before
companies go public on the blockchain i mean
they already do it's happening yeah yeah they
already do but they're just not like the official
you know ring the bell at the nasdaq or the new
york stock exchange type going public with the
sec regulation things you have these projects
these dowels these nft things they all these
coins that do stuff like they're fully operational
businesses and they release their thing and they
raise a lot of money with it and and then they
operate like this it looks different because a
lot of these are like anonymous or decentralized
or whatever but but they already happen
and there's a ton of benefits to that so
i'm waiting for the days for the next like
i don't know airbnb or whatever official
company to go on the blockchain instead of on
on wall street because there are so many benefits
to that like for starters you know who your
shareholders are right without knowing their
name necessarily but like but you can send them
a message like thank you or come see my webinar
or whatever right like that's something that they
they can sort of do it but it's really difficult
for companies to know their shoulders are
uh the only thing that's missing is regulatory
components i think that that's the only reason why
they haven't done it yet there's so much to unpack
there um we can get into regulation and all of
that but before we do i want to understand fully
your if there is a philosophical reason at all
behind your interest in crypto i know obviously
you know you were sort of going through it and you
know you realize wow there's defy automated market
makers and and all this stuff but like in times of
decentralization and stuff like that do you
feel a kind of passion towards again taking
back that control not having that centralized
control basically yes and no um you know
bitcoin launches around the same time that wall
street bets does and the language around bitcoin
obviously there's a lot of different voices but
one of the one of the voices that was heard a
lot was what you just said decentralized take
back control central banks fiat printing blah
blah blah um you know and in my case i was also
angry at the system uh because i'd been impacted
by by this crisis i'm thinking all right well if
you can't beat them join them we're not going to
be able to beat them at their own game so might
as well make money but the motivation was was
parallel it was a different approach to it right
so bitcoin tries to take on the system head on i'm
just like well let's just ride the wave along with
them there's no reason why we should fight it uh
and and these philosophies kind of evolve like
i'm not a activist i'm not a you know [ __ ] the
central bank or i feel like i you're not you're
not going to get rid of that and there's a lot
of benefits to that all right i i can go um toe
to toe with with people that are knowledgeable on
this and hold my own when it comes to to defending
the existence and acknowledging the flaws with the
ex with the existing systems that set up these
these centralized institutions i get both sides
but but i also get that you won't get rid of them
but you don't have to get you don't have to have
a winner these things already co-exist right
china tries to ban bitcoin twice a year and
they still can't right and they won't be able to
because it's part of the you know it's one of the
one of the features of bitcoin is you can't just
like there's no setting to say if if china then
don't right like yeah so so you already have
countries like el salvador you know i've read
today that ukraine is accepting bitcoin i don't
know what that means that came out four months ago
that that ukraine legalizing bitcoin but
what does that mean what does that mean
ukraine accepts bitcoin like you have a wallet i
send you a wallet okay are you like where are you
these the what's cool about like crypto is like
it doesn't ask you where you're living before you
like use it right like it's in the us they have
some restrictions if you want to use centralized
exchanges or whatever but for the most part like
you know it's just what it do you have an address
is it valid okay i'm going to go ahead and use it
so whatever whatever that means about um ukraine i
i think it solved or slightly different because
the salvatore is purchasing it right so that's
totally different completely different
so but anyway so you have you have this
this coexisting that's taking place and and i'm
cool with that but i'll tell you what motivates
me it's not like ah we're gonna get rid of
you know what power is it be because i like
the powers b if it wasn't because of the powers we
wouldn't have wall street bets we need wall street
in order to have wall street bets um but there's
a lot of problems with it i acknowledge them all
most of them some of them i disagree with and
let's fix them so let's try and fix this like
one of the things that i said is this thing is a
casino right i don't think it's fun that people
use this like a casino because last time you did
that people lost their house i lost my job so i
can complain about i can [ __ ] about it and put
a tent in front of wall street and just hold up
a sign for a few months or i can try and make
them outraged and so one of these things that i
started doing before the pandemic and then
canceled it but now restarting it is you know
i'm getting this venue at a casino in las vegas
and it's like a big stadium type thing and putting
uh an esports setup where you have like these 10
12 competitors on the stage with their computers
you know crowd streaming online and these people
are going to be trading with the stocks as if it
was a video game and they'll be actually trading
the stocks right and you're going to have the
guys that are saying oh this you know he's taking
the iron condor with tesla which is like a stock
options thing and you know that means that
by friday this thing has to do that and then
you know and and have people that are like a dave
portnoy individual and like a gem creamer and just
all sorts of characters and just make a video
game spectacle out of the stock market and why
would i want to do that because i think the
system is broken but i can do that right it's
perfectly legal i've checked many times obviously
so if like people are pissed like how can these
guys be using a las vegas casino to play with
the stock market like a freaking video game
it's amazing it's sponsored by esports things
right like and it's because i want to elicit that
change if you don't like it fix it and that's
that's my attitude and crypto does a lot of
things to fix finance right and it doesn't have to
replace one or the other but you can rub off on it
like what do i mean let's just start with 24 hour
day trading like why that's that is a setting
unlike the bitcoin china thing like you know
it trading hours equals 24 enter compile send
whatever upload like you get to go there's no
reason why market shouldn't be 24 7 and i don't
complain because i want to be up at three in the
morning but i complain because occasionally china
says we're defaulting with everground or whatever
you know you have these things that happen after
hours and those are liquidity events that really
screw up the system and it causes these crazy like
domino effects and it's bad it's systemically bad
so don't turn it off anymore so crypto can rub off
on on wall street in that effect and that's a good
thing you have these smart contract etfs they're
brilliant these are like intelligent things that
actually change based off of conditions like
awesome that helps people make money and not
just gamble it actually helps serious people too
you can make you know i was trying to come up
with when i uh a rewind i give a lot of talks
right i go to the you know people invite me to
comment and speak to these audiences and sometimes
half the time they're they're crypto the other
half the time there's stocks and they're very
binary they're like they're hardcore on whichever
side they are and i i will go to these serious
investor forums and i'll talk about wall street
bets and they want to hear about game stop it
and then i'll bring up crypto because it's
relevant and looking at me like but crypto
what's an nfc why would i buy it what's a thing
and why would i buy a pyramid scheme whatever
and then i'll go to bitcoin conferences or crypto
conferences and i will talk about both and i'll
talk about stocks because people are curious
about the thing with the game stuff and then
they stop like what is a stock and why would you
buy it and why is it not a pyramid scheme right
and so both questions from both sides is
fundamentally the same right like and they're
both fundamentally right so that's so funny yeah
so if if you're able to have crypto sorry sorry
i remember saying so crypto's able to actually do
stuff in a much better way like i i try to come up
with an example for my stock friends of saying
well what can you do in crypto that you can't
do in stocks i challenge you yeah so i thought
about it for a while and i said all right well
you know i i thought of these um liquidity
pools and these uh prediction markets
as as an example like you can already today
based off of stuff that currently exists it's
not a hypothetical set up a thing that if you own
a ski resort um you know mountain where people ski
and you're worried about the snowfall because
if it doesn't snow people don't ski you want to
hedge against that um yeah you can set up a thing
on the on the decentralized smart contract blah
blah liquidity thing where you say i'm going to
short sell inches of snow and and crypto has these
oracles that go out and read to make sure you
can trust the weather reports and and if it snows
you know you're supposed to short sell 60 inches
because that's the amount you need in order to
fill your mountain right if it's it only snows
30 then you can cash out your short sale of snow
30 inches like very to a very granular level
right and the counterparty is this decentralized
prediction market where it's not you don't have
a counterparty risk like it's a very intelligent
system and you know if it snows your 60 inches you
close out your your trade at a very small loss and
that's the price of your insurance policy and like
that's done on the fly today right like do do that
wall street you have to fill out applications
and do things and sec you know like it's just
not possible so that's cool and i think that's
really really powerful and how do you think
regulation is then going to affect this i mean
it's in a really good way like regulation lack
of regulation is the only thing holding crypto
back uh people to what extent though so like
what they legalized marijuana in the us in certain
states or they started by decriminalizing it and
in the us you'd have like colorado they say
well you can come to my store and you can buy
marijuana because here it's legal but the
federal government says this is not legal
you can't do that and banks are regulated by the
federal government so people couldn't use banks to
operate their store right so now some of
these stores have to take cash and they're
exposed to this kind of like crazy risk or
whatever if you went up to an investor says
dear investor please invest in my pot shop the
investor says you're all cash business and you
care like how are you going to pay me back
yeah duffel bags and cat like i don't so all
of a sudden you have to regulate it and all
of a sudden you can use the banks also like
and there's rules they say you can do this and
you can't do that then everyone's like all right
cool i'll invest in your in your companies and
you have like all these beer companies that are
pouring heavy money into the marijuana market
and it's growing so regulation is going to do
the same thing if you set up put a set of rules
and say hey these are the rules you can do this
and you can't do that and you have to apply here
and you need to fill out that form to do that
we can kick and screen because it's going to be
more annoying right used to be better than before
and now you have to do this thing and that sucks
but thanks to that thing that sucks uh now you'll
have a lot of money pouring into this thing and
yeah fixing a lot of problems and i'll tell you
one of the problems that i that i currently still
have with crypto like it is very difficult to use
when i first bought sorry when i got into this
thing i was like how do i buy my own coin my wall
street bets coin like oh it's easy just download
metamask and you have to set up the network
so that you can have bsc which is not to be
confused like a bep20 thing as opposed to a bep2
because that thing is not going to make you lose
all your money goes away if you screw that up it's
done because china you know blockchain's immutable
then you have to open the browser inside the thing
like jesus christ like how do you do this and
i think in large part that problem hasn't been
fixed yet because of regulation so is it gonna
is it's gonna hinder certain stuff yes but the
number of things that it will empower is going to
far out number and let me point one last thing out
um if you're able to say all right crypto is legal
but only if you use bitcoin any other derivative
like the only one we will allow you to do in the
u.s is bitcoin and you know taxes and business and
that uh and then people are like well that sucks
because bitcoin you know it's good but but but
there's a lot of better ones out there right but
you kind of have to sort of take that and say all
right well i'm going to make my bitcoin amazon or
whatever like some big ass empire and now you're
making a lot of money and i like i really hate
bitcoin because it's screwing up my transactions
i'm going to take some of my billions and
i'm going to put a lobbyist right in front of
washington i'm going to ask him to allow us to use
ethereum now something that we all really know but
we haven't been able to do because we don't have
that formalized structure and next thing you know
you'll have these lobbyists and interest groups
all these things are actually doing these things
and they'll have to fix legislation i i had this
one idea that i love i was like why don't we just
give congress all members of congress an nft
and say hey hold on to this thing this nft is
going to entitle you to an airdrop once a month
you get millions of dollars for the duration of
life as long as the mechanism by which you're
receiving this air drop continues to be legal
right so all you need to do is don't [ __ ] it up
like don't change the rules so that this becomes
illegal because then we need to comply with the
law and just cut off your like free money since
congress all you do is look for money and that's
that's what you do that is brilliant that is
actually such an interesting idea um just moving
on a little bit and we don't actually need to go
into this um i feel like i should have asked you
before um but i wondered if you've been following
anything that's been going on in canada i have
loosely i'm i'm ashamed to say i don't know the
intricacies uh but i work with uh several people
very closely that are in canada so i'm aware but i
get different takes of it right like i'll see the
twitter takes and they'll just say like canada the
truck drivers and you know the cryptocurrencies
right and then and then i'll get the takes from
my partners like yeah they're trying to annex or
not the next what's the you know they're trying
to break off and make a different country out
of ontario or quebec or whatever you know like
who the truck is i don't know what they're doing
they're just uh so so i so i i'm ashamed to say i
don't fully appreciate the nuance of what's going
on i understand that they're sick of covet like
the rest of the world and they're using that
as an excuse and the truck drivers are doing
um the thing that they find most annoying and
you know they're doing this quite effectively
yeah i mean the reason i brought this up
was because the um the prime minister justin
trudeau has said that they'll be freezing the
bank accounts of those who are people who are
supposedly involved so a lot of people are looking
to obviously bitcoin and as an alternative so i
just wondered if you had any thoughts on that but
if you're not following it then no no i did i did
see that and that actually yeah that explains all
of the if you use crypto you don't need something
like i was like there's a lot of tweets about
this today um yeah that's silly right like
i you know i think the first catalyst for
bitcoin if i remember correctly was in 2013
when cyprus was is this yeah separate haircut
they defaulted or thing and then they they froze
up bank accounts or cash phones or atm machines
whatever like they they did a thing that really
pissed off the people that had they took they
took money from people and you couldn't get you
couldn't like move your money to a safe place and
so bitcoin was this really great way to do that
and people are like wow you mean this
thing works like across countries um
anyway so i think that that's already in people's
heads for a decade so i'm surprised that justin
said this but like i will say this as i'm
following bitcoin and i'm like early on and
i'm looking at the price it goes up and down and
people are saying this is gonna the central bank
and power of the people and all these things and
you will never need to use a bank account anymore
i'm like ah that's kind of annoying you activist
you know just tone it down a few notches your
bank's not going anywhere all right like relax um
and i keep hearing it forever and it doesn't go
away even still today literally you know now we're
talking about canada then i start using crypto and
mind you i live in mexico city but i grew up
in the us i like international as it is and i
have banking in both countries make money in
both countries um you know i i at one point
figure out how to use crypto to facilitate my life
and all of a sudden i find myself like you know i
get a lot of money i'm getting yeah i'm getting a
lot of money with crypto and so i'm doing all the
kyc with the old broker so i can put it into my
bank and i do that in mexico and i do in the us
i'm like putting all this money into my bank i'm
like cool this is not just funny money it's real
money you know i go to the atm to withdraw and
i can feel it and then all of a sudden i'm like
why did i just put that into my bank that was kind
of silly right and all of a sudden like you know
what why not just keep it all in crypto and i'll
follow myself find myself taking the money that's
in my bank so i think i should put this in crypto
and next thing you know i'm looking at myself and
i'm like why would i use a bank why would anyone
ever use a bank but i don't dare say it out loud
because then i'm gonna be labeled this activist
that says like you know oh shut up you're just
trying to like promote your cryptocurrencies i'm
like no you don't understand like this thing is
so much better and it works and it's just like
you know how expensive it is i just i i do these
things and i just it was miami a couple months ago
and we did this big event and it cost a quarter
million dollars to put together i'm running all
these transactions it is a ginormous pain in the
ass like we still haven't been able to do all the
transactions because because banks and they get
in the way and i'm like you know i'm calling the
venue and i'm like yeah i'm gonna give you like
80 000 deposit but like my bank's only letting me
do it in 5 000 increments using venmo or whatever
right and i'm like sorry this is going to take a
week to get your deposit but like i can't fly to
the us to you know i call the bank of like can
i write him a check they're like no because you
can set off too many red flags i'm like but what
red flags this money came from crypto i've already
set off the flags like trust me and and all of a
sudden you know but all of a sudden i start doing
those transactions like crypto and i'm like well
that was easy yeah and i think it like we will
get to a place where we don't necessarily need
banks i mean i know that it does sound kind of
wacky um but like i i was in miami a few months
ago and i paid for my accommodation using crypto
um the airbnb because they saw who i was so they
were like we'll take we'll take bitcoin and i was
like i won't give you bitcoin but i'll give you
eth okay if they were like that's fine we'll take
um so i did that i paid my optician in miami as
well i needed to get some new contact lenses so i
paid him in tether um and yeah i paid for a lot
of things i think even i actually just got on
another apartment in miami and the guy asked me to
pay him in bitcoin and i was like absolutely not
so we i mean yeah yes and no because here here's
the thing here's a reason why banks will be really
difficult go away in order to get rid of banks you
need to get rid of fiat and you're not getting rid
of feedback in time so you don't think we will
eventually you can't because i'll tell you i'll
tell you what fiat is really good for i'm going
to tell you about letting you know on a secret
cash is great for crimes and for like laundering
money and for doing bad things and that stuff
isn't going away anytime soon but that's the
funny thing because there's like this narrative
that crypto you know especially bitcoin is um
criminal and it helps enable criminal activity
but it's cash cash is the best most anonymous form
i don't know where did that what did that st like
who came up with that like this this concept of
bitcoin is anonymous because like this thing's
like well you registered an account it didn't ask
me for my name i'm like all right cool like look
at these guys that just got nabbed the bitfinex
you know the yeah they were all over the news
you know they had like billions of dollars worth
of bitcoin and they were able to launder a little
bit of it right and they slipped up at some
point that's how they got caught but like what
what catches my attention is how difficult it
was for them to unsuccessfully mind you launder
a little bit of that money why because at some
point if you want to use the money you have to
reveal your identity this whole idea you know
mixed coin mixers all these things like you have
big data stuff they can figure it all out right
you have either computers that will attract the
things or computers that can they can monitor
for suspicious activity just like the nsa is
using metadata to figure you know they don't need
your name in order to know that you're a terrorist
because the patterns right the same thing with
the bitcoin like terrible terrible way to like
launder money or to do criminal activity so that's
why i don't think you can get rid of fiat because
there's a huge enterprise because it's useful
yeah that's hilarious that is actually so funny
um so just finally then jamie because it's me
so interesting i'm speaking with you i asked
people actually i'm gonna ask you team quite two
more questions which um people ask me to ask you
so the first question i ask you is um your father
works at the is it the world economic world
economic forum so the question is what does he do
there and how do you feel about him working for
that organization um i i did see that question by
the way you have like the coolest followers right
i've done a gazillion interviews and
podcasts and all these things and
the only person that's ever asked me about my
dad has been a mexican journalist and that's
because my dad is somewhat famous
in mexico so actually my dad is
this guy right here behind me the guy that's
on my far left right whatever side it is
he's he doesn't work at the world economic forum
but he was part of the world economic forum he
was like a global global leader of tomorrow which
is like now called young global leaders thing but
but he is a institutional banker central bank
whatever he's run a bunch of uh national you
know mexican national uh development banks as
well as multilateral banks and he's worked with
you know the imf and the all the all the three
literal acronyms and banks that you can possibly
imagine okay and he is like crazy conservative
right like his house he buys it in cash right
and he understands he's got a phd in economics
guy understands things right but he's like yeah
i get the time value of money thing but yeah
i'm not i don't want a mortgage i want my deed
his cars he pays in cash like all these things
he just does not take risks like he was running
a bank during the 2008 financial crisis his bank
was the only one like one of three in the world
that had zero exposure to these asset-backed
securities yeah those things look like they pay
you too much money and there's no free money uh
get him off the books um so he's like the anti-me
in that respect right because i'm like yolo
where's the thing to the moon here's my analysis
and i'm kicking wall street like in the nuts
with all these crazy things that are happening
uh but he is as smart as he is he has he is
a strong out-of-the-box thinker he's always
been a very unique problem solver and very unique
approach his style is completely different than
mine but he instilled that unique thinker approach
right and i think that and and he went through the
conservative politics kind of avenue and he's very
successful with that um but i think he vicariously
like is envious of my position because i
can get away with so much stuff and and i
can really ridicule a lot of stuff without having
any political blowback uh repercussions right now
oftentimes he actually like he's like you should
say this next time like somebody asks you about
that because he doesn't have the ability to but
um but he's an excellent excellent role model
and uh and we're polar opposite but he loves
what i do secretly he'll never publicly admit
it that's brilliant no that's brilliant um and
then the final question was what is the next gme
that's a good question um it's tricky so gme like
i i don't know i don't know what it is and it's
impossible to tell i can tell you kind of one
of the uh telltale signs as it's building up
but like there is no next gma because prior to
gme there wasn't necessarily a stock there was a
i don't know the infinite margin thing that i told
you about and prior to that there was like this
box spreads thing or like there's always people
that are what was the one that i saw the other day
one that dealt with warrants on the donald
trump's bag right this was an interesting arb
where you have this back which is
like a stock we'll just call it that
um it trades a certain amount but the warrants are
trading in another amount and there's a reason for
that but that reason is dumb and therefore
it legitimately is a free trade for anyone
that knows how to buy one and sell the other one
that's the type that's the next gme right like
it's this cheat code where there's free
money it's on the table gme was not just a
stock whose price went up it was a stock whose
price went astronomically up like a lot and
the reason why that went up so much had to do
with a lot of factors outside of just people
buying it which dealt with the short sellers
with the stock options whatever the market is
learned from their um uh from whatever they
want they won't allow that to happen again
using that same maneuver but i'll tell you what
the things if you start seeing a lot of chatter
stocks are going up and you see everyone's
talking about it everywhere and you start seeing
it on the news there is your next gma okay well
i will have to keep my eyes open for it because
i need to have a bite of this pie i think
that's what they say something like that
um jamie where can people follow you how can they
um join wall street bets just show yourself for
us yeah just uh follow me on on twitter it's
at wall street bets all spelled out um or the
website that that i'm working with is wall street
bets.net as far as where can they join wall street
best look there's the reddit there's discord
there's telegram there's tick-tock there's the
you know find the one you like facebook and it's
it's all the same things for different countries
there's wall street that's india and china
and south korea and then there's like
specific assets like silver and gold so just
google it and enjoy that's amazing you've just
created an entire movement um and i'm just i'm
really just like in awe of the whole movement
and everything that it represents and i think you
know how it's sort of empowering i do like the
narrative of it and powers the little man because
i think it is true and i know i i think it's
brilliant so jamie thank you so much for coming on
the show today yes thank you very much for having
me this was fun yeah absolutely and guys thank you
so much for watching don't forget to tune in this
week next week next week for another brilliant
guest until next time we'll see you then